hi my name is Leon yen I'm really happy
to be here it's my first time at PI data
I'm a data scientist in a research
engineer at NYU's social media and
political participation lab and the
Center for data science and today I'm
gonna be talking about how to make
reverse image searches using all
out-of-the-box machine learning
libraries and what is a reverse image
search it's sort of like Google's
similar images so say I want to find
other golden retrievers that look sad
you could just plug it in and you would
get some similar results
so this talk will be talking about kind
of how to reverse engineer something
similar that and so a quick overview
what's going on I'm going to talk about
a little bit about the background about
why I'm interested in this problem I'm
going to talk about what is a neural
network how do we use a pre-trained
network in Karros and how we find the
relationships between them using
scikit-learn z-- k and nearest neighbors
and then we'll see if it works and we'll
go over some questions so a little bit
of background my lab we try to see how
people use social media for political
means whether that be attending a
protest or voting for a new candidate
and also we look at how people try to
manipulate the media like a lot of what
happened during the election so I found
that images are a really important
source of conveying information and
that's kind of how we express ourselves
this time and day and age my lab mostly
uses Twitter data and we mostly look at
just metadata and text and I kind of
want to unlock a whole new ground or
research using images so there are two
ways the least that I know of how to
quantify images and so one would be the
reverse image search where you want to
find either a duplicate or something
that's very similar and then there are
classifiers where if you want a type of
thing say all pictures of dogs or Donald
Trump so we actually discovered one
working on number two so we were
building a classifier by fine-tuning a
chaos model and from doing so it kind of
unlocked how to do number one also so
number one is really good for Explorer
to
research or for personal use so if you
know I want to emphasize that this
process works with any collection of
images so all the codes available also
and it's on github and on my Twitter
account which is just my name Lee onion
so if you want to follow along please do
I'm working to document it a little bit
better as well
so the reverse image search how's this
going to work
so in a high level we're going to
leverage convolutional features from a
neural network pre-training on image net
which I'm sure a lot of you are probably
already familiar with and if you're not
then we'll learn something you and then
we'll calculate the distance between
those convolutional features using the K
nearest neighbors algorithm and
scikit-learn
so before we get started what's a real
network so this is an old parable that I
really like that describes what a neural
network is so this is an OL parable
about there's an elf in a room and a
bunch of blind men try to figure out
what it is by touching different parts
of it they each have different clues of
what they think it is and I think neural
network is very similar where you take
an input you transform it into an easily
differentiable new output or
convolutional features okay and so for
anyone who wants a less silly example
but still kind of a silly example neural
networks are basically just two things
that that happen in scale a matrix
multiplication which you could see here
with these lines those create new
features and then threshold induce ones
that are weak the features then go into
different layers and then are combined
to create new features and for anyone
who's interested in interpretability
everyone always says that you know new
neural networks are blackbox but there's
some good research going on specifically
there's this article from distill which
I'll just say that highly recommend you
read but basically expresses what is
being learned inside of a neural network
on imagenet for example they use Google
net because these are done by some
Google brain researchers and so if you
were to imagine the input being all the
way on the left and the output of
prediction being on the right first the
model learns edges and then those get
combined and they become
eaters textures and then patterns parts
and objects etc so check that out it's
really great sorry distill it's called a
distilled up pub yeah just google it
you'll find it you can search feature
visualization so what we're going to do
is we're going to create a new data set
so end up here the output but instead of
having that last layer which is simply a
regression to make a prediction we're
just going to get numbers and so we're
going to use those numbers to
essentially find similar images and so
most of these models have been
benchmarked and pre trained on this data
set called imagenet it's a it's a very
prolific computer vision data set
created at Stanford and it has about
over a million training samples and over
a thousand different classes or types of
things so there's a lot of controversy
controversy over this data set because
it might be missing certain things and
has created what some consider an ad hoc
manner but right now it is a considered
and it's used a pre trained a lot of
different convolutional neural networks
because it has a diverse set of
different shapes and colors and all the
things that you would try to look for if
you are training a convolutional neural
net and so I just want to show you how
simple it is to implement one of these
models with just one line of code and
caris you can import it I'm just telling
you the input shape which is the
dimensions of the image I want to feed
into it you have to standardize all the
images we'll go over that I'm saying
that I want to import the image net
weights so is this is a rate train for
probably around a week on image net and
then I'm saying that I don't want the
last layer which is a regression so
whenever I feed something through here
it will just return new convolutional
features and not predictions and
probabilities for a thousand different
classes so this is an example of how you
can read an image into Python so you can
read images off the web or on disk I'm
in a little convenient function which
I'm have hidden called read image so it
just reads in this link of a a
juice that thinks it's a flamingo and we
resize it to to 29 by to 29 which is one
of the square sizes that one of these
models specifically resonate 50 has been
pre trained on and this is a little
preview of that want to be duck yes and
one thing to remember is that all these
images they're just matrices that have
three color channels red green and blue
so every time you have a JPEG it's just
three color channels and a matrix we can
convert all images that are like pings
and whatnot into this format and this is
the format that the model plays best
with so implementing this is actually
pretty easy to get a new convolutional
features you can instantiate the model
using that convenience function we
defined earlier we can use a
pre-processing function that Kerris has
included which just standardizes the
data and then we can just predict it
using malla dot predict and get a
convolutional feature and then you can
drop the model and so what we've done is
we've taken this data set this image
input on the left and convert it into a
new data set in this data set is a 2048
features long I guess wouldn't be what
you say uh and you can just iron out the
extra features and make it flat and uh
you can all do you can do this in about
five lines of code so for any given
image you can just transform like that
well take a little on that specifically
so you can transform any set of images
using this to become 2,000 features 2048
and it takes about one to two hours for
a thousand using one NVIDIA GPU so if
you're using Amazon this will cost you
about a dollar two dollars and then you
can cache it and save it later so you
don't have to keep doing it for the same
image every night let's take a step back
and ask well why resonate 50 and I'll
briefly explain why which i think is
very important if anyone's trying to use
Karos and dive into neural networks so
there are there are a few other popular
implementations that already have been
trained on image net and already
pre-made on Karos and let's just take
like one second to look at a why resume
and I'll tell you why ahead of time so
resonant is great because
it creates a very information dense
output so some of the other models for
example this one which is for Inception
net it has a 50,000 features whereas
resident has 2,000 and of those features
about 33 are non zero and then 70 67
percent or so are zero so they're very
sparse and you can see that this gets
pretty out of hand too with some like
vgg for example has about like 85%
features that are zero and so I just
chose ResNet because I didn't want a
dataset that was super wide I wanted to
keep things as small as I could and have
the most information with it so I don't
need all those ones and zeros some you
know when you're doing a linear
regression at the end it doesn't really
matter but for me I just want to store
the smallest data set I can okay so
after I've transformed all that all my
data into convolutional features I want
to cluster them and find the most
similar images to assert an anchor image
to do that we use a fundamental machine
learning algorithm called the K nearest
neighbors algorithm what it does is this
image speaks for itself like so you have
an anchor image or a data point and then
you try to see the closest data points
to it by calculating distance usually
this is Euclidean distance sometimes
it's Manhattan distance so that's how
you find like closest neighbors and this
even works when you have data that has
two thousand dimensions and so this is
the path of the data set that
transformed I pretty much had about in
this case it wasn't a hundred thousand
was about thirty forty thousand images
that I transformed into these
convolutional features what the CSV
looks like I'm started in show the head
is that it's about 2048 just numbers and
then the filename and so what I'm doing
here is I'm just reading into memory I'm
getting the file name and I'm separating
out the convolutional features so we
have two two data sets two data frames
sorry one of them is convolutional
features and then
another is just a series of filenames to
keep track for everything what's
interesting is that K nearest neighbors
is also lightning fast so when I did
this with a hundred thousand images it
took about two minutes for forty
thousand it took like a like thirty
seconds or so one nice thing is that you
can paralyze it or distribute it using
of n jobs argument in scikit-learn which
is really nice and you can choose what
kind of distance calculation you want
I chose ball tree because it supposedly
works with a wider more sparse data
although rezident is considered compact
for other neural networks I think that
two thousand features it's still kind of
a lot so I chose that what's interesting
too is that if you so chose and you had
different data sets of images you can do
K nearest neighbors on all of them and
the distance for that anchor point would
be the same for all so if you wanted to
scale this with a lot of different
collections of images you could do so
and you could do it across different
machines and save them to different K
nearest neighbors models then you can
just serialize it using job Lib and so
let's recap everything that happened
this is in Python form to which just
which I've including the repo so you
just read images to a numpy array you
resize and pray process them you create
a resonant model you convert the numpy
images to convolutional features and
then you save those along with file
paths in your csv and then you send
those convolutional features to train a
cane your neighbors and then you pickle
that and so that is available on github
it's about I think a hundred and forty
lines of code and you can just input any
list of images that you want and you can
convert them so well why would you use
it let's let's make sure it works
so let's let's see what happens so for
reference the dataset that I chose were
a bunch of things I scraped from Google
Images it took about the hundred first
images per search query this was
completely random I want to make kind of
a random pool but obviously it's biased
to what I think is random so by all
means like try it yourself and put
whatever images you want into it
but I just chose like some random things
like foods and like different kinds of
trees people doing weird things and
different kinds of memes and so I've
made a little wrapper function for
getting neighbors so what this does is
it you load the two models and we're
going to use one to find neighbors and
another to convert data to find
neighbors then we convert any given
input into that format which can be fed
in K nearest neighbors to find
relational data sets we do sew up data
points then we plot them and so for this
duffel mango whoops
you can't really scroll down huh all
right we'll just look at here big sorry
folks
so for the art our friend from the past
doc flamingo we see that the closest
images to it you actually find another
duck flamingo you find two of them and
you find a whole bunch of other
flamingos again this - that's biased
because I search Koopa mingos and you
found similar things it's also really
great for duplicates so these are two
guys playing basketball we get all the
duplicates of them playing basketball
and a few more people playing basketball
community playing a tree you can see
that what they're looking at are looks
like they're looking for people and
certain stances perhaps and there's a
lot of greenery I'm seeing so color is
definitely important thing and one thing
that I've noticed a lot is that it
resonates really great at picking up
shapes and what's cool too is if you
want something like tweets which is we
get a lot of images of screenshots of
tweets you can search for those too and
you'll get other things that are also
screenshots of tweets and other texts
similar things all right so let's go
back to the official thing okay so some
next steps that I'm interested in doing
so right now I'm trying to expand how
many platforms up images of right now we
started with Twitter I'm starting to get
some of the different parts of the web
where a lot of like white-supremacist
hang out so I didn't share that on
purpose because I don't want to show you
guys a bunch of awful images so that's
why it shows flamingos but we're working
on looking at how I
do you spread and a lot of those ideas
that are spraying these days are
propaganda and toxic and white
supremacist ideas I want to know how to
get this to be used by people who aren't
data scientists so although you know I
can create one function that does this
it'd be really nice heavy of a UI and I
saw similar one that Ethan hello created
yesterday and so yes I will perhaps take
some inspiration from that so thank you
for open sourcing that and I want to see
if analogies work so we look at means a
lot so be really cool to see if you can
multiply these late these convolutional
features into one vector and see what
comes out from after that for example
you know there's a lot of memes are
remixed so we can put one on one side
one on the other and see if it pops up
and you find the remix just idea thank
you I will take questions now
[Applause]
those images are very
um that's a really good question so I've
seen this same technique by ethan and
others using the fashion history and
they also have similar patterns like
floral prints what you could do also is
have different size of images so perhaps
have a zoom in if you want a specific
texture but one thing that did come out
of that distill article I showed earlier
is that these models pay a lot of
attention to textures and and different
edges so I would guess that it could do
that it's worth a try yeah and to try it
it's not very hard like you can just use
code like this and it's about 100 lines
of code the hardest part is configuring
Karros and tensor flow they can be a
little finicky so I would just make sure
to do that right that's the hardest part
yes
it's fresh boundaries
I'm trying to understand the question
correctly so I don't retrain the now
Kratt all I'm just piggybacking on
imagenet and it's pretty represented it
tries to be representative all the
things out there but there are probably
combinations of shapes and things that
it hasn't seen it doesn't know how to
categorize it also just own the only
context that has an image too so if you
have to visually similar things that'll
confuse the two and that can get you in
a lot of trouble sometime for example
Google had this thing with a bunch of
gorillas and then it also had pictures
of black people because there's no
context and so if you just look at
without context you know I mean yeah
these datasets are missing a lot it's
harder to know what it's missing to
compensate for that and to make sure
that they're fair and accurate but
that's kind of why image net is being I
don't want to say well that's why people
are questioning how good image net is
these days and trying to figure out
better representations of what is
representative yes
that's good question the question is
what how and why did I choose K nearest
neighbors
well the dumb answer is that it just
seemed like the best simplest answer and
the real answer is that I haven't tried
anything else cosine similarity similar
word vectors would be interesting to
look at I'm really and so I saw a lot of
parallels to word and bendings like were
Tyvek which create latent
representations of text and I don't
think that this is that different from
from from those kind of latent vector so
I try out cosine similarity and maybe a
few more metrics but yeah
I chose Kenya sternum is because it
could scale well and it was easy to
deploy and it's very interpretable
yes hi
mm-hmm okay the question is how do I
validate what comes out are there
benchmarks I have not done any of that
yet I would really like to that's my
answer
yes
it depends on what you're trying to do
if you're sure
sure up to me so a lot of times when you
normalize you're actually losing
information and for me I want to keep
all information so when you're doing
what traditionally you're right like you
would normalize and regularize the data
before the last step which is the
regression but because I didn't have a
regression I just decided to just keep
it as is but I definitely try around
with some activation functions for sure
yeah yes
the size to 2048 features per image my
last remark if there no more questions
is that Karos is a really great way to
get introduced to neural networks but if
you're an engineer and you like numpy
check out pi torch it's very intuitive
you can do a lot more with it I just
tried Karos because I was this is my
first this was my first exposure to
doing neural network stuff I was doing
fine tuning which meaning which means I
pretty much did the same thing but I
included the last layer trying to
classify something but uh pipe torch is
really awesome I suggest checking out
Kara's joining around that and then
check out pi torch if you're interested
in your own networks
[Applause]